remember when Donald Trump and
Republicans passed their tax plan and I
told you that this tax plan was going to
allow Donald Trump to claim two
victories victory number one that he did
tax reform even though the tax reform he
did was the opposite of what the tax
reform he promised to do would have done
in terms of its effect on on people
secondly the tax bill would allow Trump
to say that he repealed Obamacare it's
not true but it was going to let him say
it the tax plan that Trump and
Republicans passed did make a change to
Obamacare it eliminated the individual
health care mandate which says every
individual must have some kind of
insurance or pay a fine but Trump is now
selling it as if he did straight-up get
rid of Obamacare Trump did another one
of these really weird rallies in
Michigan recently and he said
essentially we are getting rid of
Obamacare some people would say
essentially we have gotten rid of it now
this is a lie but this is predictable we
knew that Donald Trump was going to sell
this to his followers as having put
Obamacare in total in the trash even
though most of Obamacare is still in
place but there's another further layer
to chunk Trump's lie the Trump
administration is actually enforcing
some aspects of Obamacare more strongly
then the Obama administration did and
Republicans as well as some business
owners are angry with Trump for that so
for example Trump got rid of the
individual mandate but the employer
mandate is still there the employer
mandate says if you have a company with
more than 50 full-time employees you
must offer health insurance to workers
or pay a fine that's still in place and
according to numerous reports that is
not just in writing as part of the law
it is being enforced businesses are
actually being fined under Trump for not
offering health care when they're
supposed to based on Obama care law so
the big picture is the exchanges still
exist the coverage requirements exist
right health insurers aren't allowed to
go back to those disastrous plans that
didn't even meet the minimum insurance
insurance conditions of Obamacare the
pre-existing conditions requirement is
still there the corporate mandate is
still there it's all still
there other than the individual mandate
Obamacare in total exists with the
exception that if you don't have
coverage you won't pay a fine and all
that does is make coverage more
expensive for people because the idea is
the fines make more people choose to
have coverage that grows the risk pool
spreads risk among more people and in
principle companies don't have to charge
as much for health insurance so this is
not a matter of opinion right it is a
lie to say that Donald Trump has gotten
rid of Obamacare whether he says we
essentially got rid of it or we got rid
of it either way it's not true and
there's a funny and tragic element to
this which is that Trump said dozens or
hundreds of times during the campaign
that he would not only get rid of
Obamacare but he was gonna replace it
with a beautiful new system where
everyone would be covered for less money
than under Obamacare if Trump believes
that he got rid of Obamacare which is
what he's saying he did where is the
beautiful replacement that he told us we
would have because even if he claims to
have gotten rid of Obamacare which he
didn't there's no question that he
hasn't come up with a replacement which
he also said that he would do normal
people would realize that this is a lie
right and the most interesting
perspective I'm thinking about is are
enough Republicans falling for this that
it will actually earn him votes in the
fall like in other words are people
going to reward Trump and Republicans
for quote getting rid of Obamacare even
though they didn't and vote for
Republicans and Trump in November
because in reality if they want to vote
on the basis of did Trump do what he
said he would do
they should not be voting for Trump I
have a feeling that this is going to
convince a lot of people I think this is
the lie that he will get away with and
it's because most Trump supporters
aren't employers with 50 or more
employees so they don't have to deal
with that correct the thing that they
didn't like about Obamacare was the
individual mandate and maybe they liked
some of the other specific provisions
like staying on your parents health care
till you were 26 sure so in the eyes of
most people he did what he set out to do
mission accomplished there's another
issue also which is that not only are
most Trump voters as you're saying not
owners of businesses with more than 50
full-time employees they're also mostly
not on
marketplace plans meaning most of them
have insurance through their employer so
they're not even connected to this
individual mandate like it existed for a
while and it didn't impact them and then
now it's gone and it still doesn't
impact them and it's completely a sort
of academic or theoretical thing so I
think you're completely right this is a
lie that Trump is going to benefit from
he did it he got rid of Obamacare even
though he got rid of 1% of Obamacare or
5% one specific provision here that's my
question to you will Republican voters
fall for this lie from Donald Trump I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show support for
today's show comes from ever quote
America's largest online marketplace for
auto insurance only 5% of drivers pay
under $50 a month for auto insurance
nationally but ever quote is helping to
change that with a proprietary matching
algorithm that helps you find the right
coverage at the right price and in fact
data shows that users who find their
auto insurance through ever quote save
an average of five hundred and thirty
six dollars per year no wonder over
three hundred thousand shoppers use ever
quotes insurance matching services every
day take advantage of ever quotes
cutting-edge data and analytics and go
to every quote dot-com slash Pakman to
compare coverage options today